我主要說三件事情
一個是其實我們上次講的那個講一次利率
因為上週又出了那個通脹
然後通脹的數據我分析大概通脹的數據
然後這次加息的預期
然後最近以來
宏觀的我認識的反正宏觀H房
基本上對AI或者對於整個市場風險投存都非常不一臂
所以我說一下市場倉位
然後利率最近對市場影響
我就結合一下
過去吧因為大家擔心的都是看的是18年23年
這兩年在深系的週期中間其實市場跌了很多
然後我說一下這兩次週期的市場基本上的一個狀況和這次的比較
然後第三個最近討論很多也導致昨天
美股市場下錯比較嚴重的就是那個
AI的監管的問題
然後因為三大三個廠就Elon和Enthalpy OpenAI
他們都出來講然後AI的監管其實我覺得最後真正的背景
是美國的左派們
害怕失去
為了奪權在中紀選舉之前造了一波大比較大的新聞
然後
這個東西來龍去脈以及後面對市場大概會有一個什麼樣的影響
然後我正好這有Discord先把關掉
然後花比較有稍微有點聲音又把它關一關
然後
大概這幾方面的東西吧然後我先說一下
CPI的數據
CPI數據其實可以結合到上一次能方payroll的數據一起來說
能方payroll我上星期講過
中間有
那個季節性的調整
季節性調整來自於一方面來自於世界盃
有個
6萬人的那個酒吧的工作然後另外一部分部分來自於Local Education
地區的那個
教育工作因為快開學了嘛所以
有這一部分季節性的回升
然後
通脹的數據裡面有很重要的一個調整是手機
Wireless
也就是如果你把Wireless跑掉Wireless在6月份的時候是下降的
所以
你把如果把Wireless跑掉的話是460.2但你不能說直接這樣跑掉嘛
這個通脹數據是超出了預期一點
當時高盛的預期好像0.23吧
就是那個就悶桑悶桑大概0.23吧
然後最後出來0.29
但是這個0.29的數字通脹並不是是not a day
就不是這個特別特別差的一個通脹數據
也當然你看Helen number
就只是看那個
數據本身的話
數據本身一方面你看到通脹
有一點加速比較稍微偏快一點
然後你看到就業數據很好
所以如果只是看數據那聯儲就應該加息
那我覺得聯儲
週三好像週三是真的會加息
因為加息並不是為了我覺得聯儲這次要去加息的話
他並不是真的為了說通脹要失控了
然後我們
我們必須要去控制通脹去加息
而是Wash在前面放了很多硬化
你放了硬化看數據最後數據出來確實不好
你沒有餘地了
我覺得是這樣一種加息的狀態如果發生加息
所以就是一個叫quadability
就maintain fact quadability的一次
一次hike
但是我為什麼寫topic叫做quadability hike into supply shock
也就是在supply shock在供應端需求的時候
供應端那個通脹的時候
你加息其實是沒有用的
也就是你今天如果看通脹
大家擔心說有通脹
通脹來自於哪裡
來自於CPI不是來自於核心CPI
空CPI
空CPI不是那麼高
又說你的
你的那個石油價錢對通脹印象沒有那麼大
那麼美聯儲看的是哪一個
不是CPI
是核心CPI
只是
為了維持主席的
聯儲主席之前講的比較強硬的話
他現在在這個
節點上面他在政治上
已經沒有什麼迴旋餘地了
在政治上沒有迴旋餘地意味著他的經濟上也沒有
也就是你今天如果不假席下次如果不假席
那麼10年會撕給你看
就短期裡面10年可能會往上跑很多
然後撕給你看
就說你聯儲pricing聯儲不控制通脹
所以
Inanimate benefit就是包括對於割派的人來說
也應該加一次所以我覺得聯儲裡面
我聽說是割派的那批人的反饋就是
比較猶豫對於加息是猶豫的
但是他們也可以順從去加一次息
所以這是加一次息
那麼概率大概現在
從CPI出來以後從69
掉到86
那麼昨天下跌跟
我覺得跟宏觀沒有那麼大關係
因為如果宏觀相關的話他星期五就跌了星期五沒有特別大的反應
昨天主要是
主要主要是AI的監管要帶有
那麼我來說一下
這個加息的預期上去很多
然後我們over time在過去一段時間從
從Wash發言到現在
就是每一次兩次東西從Jackson後之後說我們看數據
然後比較強硬的看我們看數據然後一次培柔一次CPI
那兩次連續驗證之後現在到了86
剛才談上也下不來所以我覺得它是有可能加息的
但是現在加息情況是不是被整個市場pricing太多或者是不是被 fully pricing
我覺得被 fully pricing
到明年這是整個調EU curve
也就是現在在變成一條更加steep的EU curve
這代表著說什麽東西呢也就是更steep的EU curve
代表著說
我們經濟發展不會被吃厚
我們增長還是很快
但是我們再加息
但是從整個需求端來看並不完全是這樣子
就現在我們
定價多少次定價大概3.5次昨天晚上我這個數據沒有更新
昨天晚上可能到了4次吧
那麽
整個
community整個社區裏的
micro hatch fund對沖基金
然後特別是那些看宏觀的我覺得
對沖基金其實宏觀 hatch fund不是一定去做股票個股
更多的是聽了宏觀對沖基金的看法
然後那幫做股票的不懂宏觀的人在裏跑
然後再逃跑大部分是這樣的
然後這幫這幫人跑的理由就是每一次加息的時候都會爆點
然後確實如果你看2018年
就是2018年這個周期
看2022年這個周期
都是20到25的這個回調
那麽
是不是一定是說加息就是
我們美聯儲加息就是整個市場一定要跌爆掉
我來分析一下就是18年
其實主要我們看18年和23年的兩次
也就是
不光是加息本身
我覺得更多的是市場對於加息的預期
以及市場後來就是美聯儲最後deliver了多少次加息
這個東西才是
市場會漲會跌的一個最重要的原因
那麽
加息我上次講過就是
我們過去的經濟增長大部分是依靠流動性去提供的
過去20年30年
都是靠流動性提供
所以本身對美聯儲就會很敏感
那麽在現在應該對美聯儲敏感度沒有以前那麽高
因為我們在AI裏面就整個美國和西方的經濟
主要是美國
美國經濟在這幾年裏面它的確提高了proactivity
提高了它的這個效率
因為AI在提高
包括現在投資比方說AI的
CAPEX投入
CAPEX投入因為受益高嘛所以拼命才投CAPEX
這一部分其實對那個
對原來的美聯儲的這個
這個公式也沒有那麽明顯
所以進入了一個其實在2024年
2024年25年以後
整體經濟環境進入一個不是跟過去20年非常相同的一個週期
狀態不是很一樣
但是我們就拿2018年和20年這兩件事情來講
2018年為什麽跌爆掉?為什麽跌這麽多?
其實你們想過2018年跌是因為加息嗎?
不是因為加息
是因為市場沒有預料到加那麽多次
2018年的加息的週期是15年週期的延續
它是一個週期
15年開始要去加息的時候
然後市場預計它要加4次
那個時候想的還是把2008年那個週期
但是15年因為美聯儲最後其實checking out了就是
慫了嘛
所以最後那個它市場定價了它加兩次Fed到加了4次
最後它加了一次
就基本上沒怎麽加
那麽使得市場其實認為我們會在一個很長期的DC的環境裏面
當時美國其實經濟增長也是基本上也是靠美聯儲
當然沒有一個新的這個沒了新的一個生產效率提高點
所以
市場在18年的時候已經整整經歷了10年DC的環境
已經既定俗成了就市場已經
已經忘記08年以前利息漲什麽樣子
就是高息的環境是長什麽樣子
所以當美聯儲真正加了3次利息再加QT
其實它主要加加QT的時候
市場在最後
暴跌的那個點
這個是18年
暴跌那個點下去的時候是不知道你利息會跑到哪裏去
最後會不會加多少它是不清楚的
是超過了市場預期
所以18年暴跌跌了20 跌了19
更慘的是2年
那麽這個我們大概記憶優行吧
2年的時候
加息本身是智候於同障
也就是
2年的時候跟現在不一樣的是2年
2年和18年甚至15年核心通脹都上來
就核心通脹有很多的點包括我們看到的我們之前講的那個
消費啊消費信貸啊然後房租啊這些東西都上來
所以在這些東西都上來的過程過程當中
2年是智候之前那個
JPOW說Inflation Transitory
是臨時的是戰時的
然後到了2年
3月份開始加息的時候
那麽市場一下子定價了6次加息
最後加了16次加17次反而我這個寫錯
加17次反而是
16次加17次利息
所以
這個過程這兩次基本上你看到暴跌並不是說加息直接滑等號暴跌
而是說超過預期的加息滑等號暴跌
市場黑顏色的東西是連儲的Fat道
當然現在這個Fat道沒有那麽精準因為本質上
那個叫什麽Kevin Walsh是沒有給Fat道連儲的主席是沒有給Fat道的
但是連儲的委員們其實是給的
也就是你給4次市場定兩次你加了一次之後市場越來越不會發生
然後2次2次你加3次6次6次你加16次
現在市場的記憶是什麼
市場記憶跟2015年是不一樣的
我們現在記憶是18年和22年18年和23年
22年和23年
你看所有在
公開媒體上包括推特上小紅書上他們去講宏觀的那批人
然後因為宏觀擔心市場利率會掉下來或是市場暴跌的人
其實他們眼睛看的都是18年和22年和23年
那麽這兩個週期是到底是怎麽一回事是超預期週期
現在美聯儲定價就是你要看Fat道的話雖然
主席沒給那其他人還是大部分給了一個我們後面的預期
Fat道你看到的是一次
市場定價3.5次昨天晚上定價可能到4次了
定價3.5次4次
然後你最後準備加多少你要暴跌你得加5次
你要超過美聯儲的基準預期然後你要在這個3.5基準再至少要加到5次4次5次
那麽有沒有這個基礎加上去
我覺得是沒有
就period一句話
句好沒有
句好
為什麽沒有
看三個四個時代的經濟數據
我們先看紅顏色這個工資上漲
工資上漲在15年的時候基準利率0.1
工資上漲超了基準利率2.3
然後18年的時候基準利率1.4
工資上漲超了大概1.2
你不能光看這個工資上漲本身
而是要看工資上漲相對於利率
基準利率是多少
相對於通漲高了多少
就是這個有沒有螺旋在上升
就我比通漲是不是還要高在螺旋上升
那你現在看我們現在的這個工資上漲
工資上上3.1
核心通漲3.3
它是低於通漲率都低於利率的
所以這個3.1的數據你hardly說
它有工資螺旋上漲的任何的信號都沒有
所以現在其實我覺得就是過於高的定價
這是為什麼
這是最核心的紅顏色最核心的數字
這個是為什麼我一直在說
它過於高的定價了通漲的這個升息的預期
升息4次5次是市場的恐慌的交易出來
然後除了這個是外
通漲核心通漲還有一些其他因素
核心通漲一方面消費推動
工資推動消費最後推動了所有東西
美國經濟是靠消費50%靠消費
所以消費推動了所有東西
那麼消費裡面 consumer credit借錢在消費
這個東西的增長是多少
這也是非常重要會影響到核心
核心通漲率
比方說15年的時候4.6.6
就是這個來的嘛 6.6.9
然後上一次9.1
當然這時候是有疫情的
你這個國家的錢和信貸的錢進入經濟體
現在2.6
你看這些數據
全部低於核心通漲率
就是你不管是 consumer credit
還是 out of wage
就是每個小時的工資
包括你的房租增長
全部低於核心通漲率的
現在是這樣一個狀態
那麼我們核心通漲率哪裡來的呢
核心通漲率是商品來的
商品帶來的
商品中間有一塊是關稅
是我們可愛大總統加了關稅
然後他發動了伊朗戰爭
導致了伊朗的油價再漲
這個東西帶來
這些東西我們叫做
所以我們叫 supply shock
就是供應端的這個衝擊
你加息其實是沒有用的
加息能夠壓制的是這些東西
能夠把這些東西壓得更低
但是你對於供應端沒有影響
或者說你要等到製造一個衰退
才對供應端影響
我覺得最近還有一個無極之談
是說美聯儲想製造一個衰退
來控制油價
Come on
美國是 du-mandate
它一方面它不是ECB
它一方面要管通漲
ECB還是看通漲率
只看通漲率
然後美國是要看通漲和增長
美聯儲其實它的 mandate
既然是 du-mandate 兩個都要的話
它一般來說
會把增長放在通漲前面
這是過往幾十年
從那個 walker 除了 walker
就是 walker 以外
除了 walker 以外
任何一個美聯儲主席
包括70年代開始
都是把增長其實放在通漲上面
因為 walker 那個時候是因為通漲
影響時間太長太久遠太嚴重了
所以它更加傾向於通漲
這個是比較獨立的一個
比較特立的一個美聯儲主席
但是我們現在如果是要把這些都壓下去
像是一個核心通漲
其他指標全部壓下去
然後去控制油價
去製造一個通縮去控制油價
衰退控制油價
我覺得這個是無極之談
而且油價也不是你一家人在需求的
中國增加一下產能需求
中國增加一下負責
油價一樣會動
所以與其說你要去讓美聯儲去收錢
去控制油價
你還不如讓特朗普快點別打
或者是這個事情快點去消停吧
所以這是我本質
我認為整體經濟完全沒有辦法支持
一個長期的加息
但是Nonnales無論這個東西
長期的加息三年五已經被停價了
而且整個Curve都已經被拉起來
所以在利率上面
我個人感覺是過度定價
這個高盛有個有個家伙說了一句話
我就問問是誰在Macro
Global就在一個Weekend Macro Call上講
也就是我們加息是沒有辦法多製造出來
一桶油的
我們加息也沒有辦法生產出來
就我講加息沒有辦法多生產出來
一塊芯片
所以你現在所有的supply side
就是供應端的矛盾
都沒有辦法通過加息來解決
那麼在美聯儲內部也有同樣的聲音
只是這次的隔派
他們也很清楚
為了維護美聯儲的一個信用
快著背的點
你話都已經放到這裡了
很有可能同意你去加息
加息的概率現在被提高到86% 90%
但是你在持續性的加息的時候
在美聯儲內部一樣會面臨阻力
大家都清楚
你在做一件沒有什麼用處的事情
然後即使
那麼退一半不來說
你即使今年後面
比方說10月份
10月份我覺得很難
然後你比方說後面中期選舉之後
你繼續加息
包括明年繼續加息
即使如此
你真的加了
你也就是符合預期
市場已經pricing了
就這些東西已經定價了
所以我看到宏觀對沖基金門
和宏觀的這些企業
大部分在做空的時候
一個原因在宏觀上就覺得利率
第二個原因其實是因為石油
石油是我有點不勝確定的事情
然後但是這個不確定性
都已經被定在裡面
因為
胡在武中不是也在紅海
騷擾人家那個航線
第三個原因是
大家已經定價了
美國的hyperscale的借錢
可能明年inacted cash flow
付錢金流
明年付錢金流
但是
但是我反正看到
整體的快樂 spread
現在也沒有動
所以包括中期選舉
也就是把所有的宏觀上各方面
你們認為負面的信息
現在市場都變成市場
要出逃的一個理由
然後整體的倉位現在比較輕
就是我們沒有看到重新releveraged
net interest就是我們叫做
net position在
hatch fund還沒有降太多
但是fundamental fund其實降了很多
也就是他們其實手上都倉位越來越低
對相對來說都比較低
那麼整體市場的估值
或者我們說一個SMP應該是什麼價錢
你不能說7600點
或者多少點
這個東西背後其實帶著盈利的
你應該看4P來代表
我真正的估值在那裡
4P已經被壓制了很久了
壓制了大概大半年了吧
然後現在的4P
就是說我們從SMP估值角度來講
就SMP的價值
你肯定不能說你現在7000點
和去年的7000點
那是完全不同的兩回事情
所以現在的SMP的價格
其實離關稅的時候
關稅最最嚴重的那一天
也就貴了5%
這個5%的體現在哪裡
就是體現在我們剛剛講的所有的擔心
這些擔心都被pressing
大家因為這些擔心都跑掉
所有人都在外面
現在fundamental fund
hatch fund
他們都在外面
頭上都是很空的
因為沒有人
對於對沖基金
我今天早上跟一個朋友也聊到這個事情
就是為什麼你說對沖基金他們跑
其實基金並不是看絕對收益的
基金是不要踩雷
然後能夠搞好投資人關係
他是客目資的
所以你如果在美聯儲加息之前
你進去去買
然後你買錯了
你是很難跟投資人解釋的
你會覺得你還會覺得你很蠢
但是你在美聯儲加息之前
你逃跑了
然後他漲回去了
你可以說我避下風險
你是沒有錯的
你是不會有問題的
所以這個和個人投資是完全不同
他不是追求絕對收益
他追求的是一個帶著Vol的手藝
或者是他追求的是一個
可以跟投資人交代的手藝
所以他去放跑掉
我覺得很正常
我拿去幫我也會跑
然後但是我們還得清楚認識到
現在的增長是很高的
整個S&P的增長是很高
在這種增長的環境裡面
包括業界增長是很solid
非常確定
我們給了一個極低的固執
現在整個S&P是19.3
就是比關稅那個18.1
然後高了1%
5%多吧
5%多一點
昨天跌完
這個是我星期五的數據
所以昨天跌完的時候
可能更加差一點
所以在這個位置上面
如果是一個Long term investor
我覺得不應該太看短期裡面
太多的噪音
各種噪音
其實一旦不對業績影響的新聞和噪音
那麼這個東西就是噪音本身
也就是個新聞而已
當然了
昨天市場為什麼跌很多
昨天市場有個原因
就是幾家
其實這故事最早是一個
Enthorpy的員工叫Jackoff
然後他離開了
他可工作了6個月
然後離開了公司
出去發推
在一個幾乎沒有
他原來幾乎是沒有follow的
一個X平臺上面
然後他去發推
說AI在十年裡面要把所有人都弄死
但是這個事情本身
他放棄了公司的集權股份
這個我覺得任何媒體的事件本身
後面都是會有力量在推動
你也不知道是誰的力量
但我覺得左派力量肯定是有的
因為馬上就連鎖引爆
包括Warsbury channel
包括Bernie Sanderson
就是議員
大家一起在討論這個事情
變得非常熱
甚至到了Dalio出來講
我們接受那個監管什麼的
然後說我們確實要讓AI的模型
訓練變得更慢
然後讓市場擔心
然後OpenAI當然也出來說
那個Elon也出來說
本質的問題我覺得分開兩步
就是這是一個被各方政治勢力
反覆引用
然後投機的一個事件
在這裡面真正笑到最後的
只有中國
因為AI變慢
美國的AI變慢
獲利的只有中國人
但是這個裡面
每個人都有自己的利益
就比方說這個小朋友
這個小朋友和左派
他們肯定是利益是一致的共同體
那麼不管小朋友出於聖母親也好
出於要做聖人也好
但是他肯定是被左派在利用
左派要利用AI的事情
去打擊他老公政府
要為了自己的中期選舉
和下一次選舉
他的口號肯定是反對
要反對這些東西
然後達利歐什麼去應對呢
他可能是想打擊一下開源模型
因為達利歐最不能夠接受的
包括Anthope不能接受一件事情
因為我們現在看到很樂觀的
特別是在開源模型廠
在CSP的
在微軟和Microsoft他們這裡
看到的是投資收益
六個月就回報
非常賺錢
那麼你當你繞過了模型公司
變得非常賺錢
變成雲廠上說了算的時候
就這個定價權變成
變到雲廠大頭的時候
這個是兩家labs
本身是不太能夠接受的
所以即使頂著要上市
達利歐有去講這個話
他這個人通常都是屬於喜歡
這種語不盡人死不休的
然後他要去說我要去監管
其實監管本身的你
我都被監管了
那誰來監管開源模型呢
你們這些公司是不是不要去用
開源模型
最好是這樣
那伊隆和SAM
在就是Opniac和Elon Musk
那麼就Elon Musk手上有個Glock
他們其實本身也不一定很希望
Antopia非常順利的去上市
現在Antopic融不到錢
Opniac會更強
Opniac可以自己建算一中心
他融了錢更多
那麼大家一起
可以說大家一起軍備競賽
降降速
然後他們就會跳出來說這個話
其實真正傷到的是誰
那你Antopic後面還怎麽上市
你講了這個話
大家都要說
slow down了你還怎麽上市
中國會slow down嗎
中國的開源模型們
就是中國那些區域模型的人
他會關注AR會不會
你們美國左派所擔心的
AI的監管問題
我擔心嗎
中國沒有
所以我就說
當左派們去炒作AI監管
唯一消到最後的是習主席
和中國的模型廠
他們不在乎這個東西
包括你可以看到
美國表明說部署電力的成本
美國建核電站
今天早上有個朋友說
美國建核電站成本
可能是中國15位
因為有各方面的監管
美國建一個礦場的成本
是中國很多位
這個不光是人力
這是各方面的還品和左派們建立的
各種的這個壁壘
所以AI的各方面
就是我們現在要不要建立
這樣的一個壁壘的問題
所以這個我覺得是長遠
可能就是對AI缺乏的
我們的交易會產生一些影響
但是如果把政治的因素拋開
在利率上面
我不覺得有什麽問題
就整體在利率上
不覺得有什麽問題
利率現在被 overpriced
整體利率都被 overpriced
另外說一個
包括我剛剛本來想講一下
ECB
ECB和日本兩家
其實都在變得更加強硬一些
但是整體市場的
你可以看到整體市場的quad
其實不支持
global全球的大家一起強硬
一起變硬盤
一起加息
這個是不止持的
債務情況就不止持
日本的債務情況
美國債務情況
整個歐洲債務情況
其實都不是很好
所以當你ECB要變強硬
日本也要變強硬
這種過程當中
我們就在看
現在大家已經把這個東西
全部pricing
pricing之後
你應該看的就是
下面一個infection point
是什麽時候
我記得非常清楚是2012年
那個歐洲危機之前
歐洲好像還加了一次利息
然後定價錯誤之後
後來回頭
那坎的比前面加的兇得多
因為最終你有沒有能力去加息
你有沒有能力長期
high of longer
覺得就是看你利息成本
除了美國
他是global去全球貨幣
美國利率是全球貨幣
你們這些人有沒有能力
長期去持有
你們這貨幣不是global貨幣
不是全球貨幣
所以你們有沒有能力去長期
把利率弄得更高
我覺得其實是沒有的
回過頭來剛剛講到日元和美元
日元和美元也是一樣
其實在現在情況下
我們剛剛講
不但在利率上被overpriced
同時的話
市場很恐慌
但是我沒有上升
市場恐慌情緒很高
我沒有上升
不是代表我一定會上升
而是現在cross asset
在不同的資產上面
波動率都沒有上來
這個包括了我們看到的
這包括了我們現在
比方說看到的acquity wall
股票的波動率
你這個是我們自己的籃子
就是AI的籃子
股票的wall
相對來說
你們要說一個星期是比較低的
然後同時的話
包括了利率的wall
就是你那個rate wall
包括了dollar yen
比方說匯率的wall
包括了你的quiet spread
quiet spread在那裡
我看一下rate wall
對swap signal
swap signal稍微上來一些
因為最近在加上
稍微稍微上來一些
swap signal
我覺得可能是唯一一個
最近短時間上來一些
但是
比方說你的quiet spread
全部都沒有上來
所以這種情況下
就是你有如此恐慌的情緒
但是波動率沒有上來
我覺得在這個時間點上
而且大家都倉位都比較輕
在這個時間點上
要保持景深樂觀
對整個市場要保持景深樂觀
即使所有人都可能跟你講
加息了我這個市場要點
但我覺得可能不一樣
當所有人都告訴你
加息的市場要跌的時候
語言音是加息的幅度
就我剛講加息的幅度
超過了語言來市場預計
但是現在已經定價3.5次了
我們現在至少和22年不一樣
沒有像22年這麼嚴重通常
那現在定價3.5次
已經遠遠超過18年
所以我個人是保持景深樂觀
然後可能唯一的擔心
就是監管的問題
但是監管的問題
議會是不能夠自己形成一個監管
它最終還要通過總統
那麼通過行政部門
所以我們這位大總統還有兩年
那這個情況下
就是說後面怎麼看
到後面再看
但是至少現在這任政府是pro-business
你別管它腐敗不腐敗
但是它肯定暫時是pro-business
盡量pro-business
當然沒有中國這麼pro-business
還是偏pro-business
然後最後說一下油價
我油價聽說的小學是這樣子
就人這也不一定
這是我們聽了一個call
就是油價上面
我們聽說傳東們通過
火塞武裝控制的海域的時候
只要付錢就可以
也就是這些人也沒有什麼真正的
這個伊斯蘭教信仰
他們其實也是屠材
ILGC不給他們錢
或者ILGC自己沒錢
就革命會對自己沒錢了
那種情況下
他們也是需要去尋財的
所以製造一些矛盾
製造一些問題
其實最終花錢是能夠過的
所以我不知道
就使用這個東西
我覺得整體利率
就至少在短期裡面
五年期利率
然後利率和石油定價都挺滿的
在這種情況下
就是你當你定價比較滿的時候
我覺得再多頭來說
可能更加安全一點
然後這個更新了一下出去
現在94
現在加息概率到94
所以這周你基本上市場定價
就幾乎肯定加息
是這麼一個狀態
好吧
那謝謝大家的時間
我今天我看到大家有什麼問題
趕緊做一下Q&A吧